-Welcome! -Yes.
-Welcome back! It is always -- -Back in the house.
-It is always great to see you.
You look great. -Thank you.
-Is this true, what I just -- My intro?
-Was that true? -50 years?
-Was that -- No. That can't be true. No. 50 years?
I was 20 -- That would make me 20-something --
When I was 23, I was pounding the pavement in New York.
-Yeah. -Trying to find a job.
-Yeah, you weren't getting -- -I was going to auditions
and, you know, jumping the subway turnstile.
-Yeah, yeah, exactly, yeah.
-Because I couldn't afford to ride -- pay for it.
Because we weren't making any money
doing showcases or whatever, yeah.
-But just this year,
you're going to receive an Oscar for your work.
-Yeah! -And, so, congratulations.
-Thank you. [ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on. How great is that?
-You know, it's pretty dope to, like, have an Oscar presented
to you by the governors of the Motion Picture Academy.
-That's exactly right.
-The other way you to get it is cool, you know, be voted on
because you did a great picture,
but, I mean, this is like saying that, you know,
I've done what I set out to do,
which was be a great entertainer,
get people come to the movies, have a good time.
-Yeah, and you actually -- You've done more than that.
-Grab some stuff, and, you know --
I put a couple asses in seats.
-Yeah, you have.
Are you going to do -- Is there a speech?
Are you going to be giving a speech?
-Yeah. Yeah, that one. The one I just gave.
[ Laughter ]
-You have to do something.
-I've got to call some names, you know.
-You know what? I was looking. There's a list of someone
who said the most swear words in movie history.
And I was like, "Oh, yeah." -Who is it?
Who won? -It's not you.
It's Jonah Hill.
-That's some bull [bleep]. I mean, that's --
♪♪
I mean -- I mean, no.
[ Laughter ]
-That's better. No. -No way, man.
-No way, man.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, no way, man. -No way, man. Come on.
-So Jonah. Then Leo. -Jonah Hill? Really?
-And then you. -And Leo?
-That feels impossible to me.
-Jonah Hill then Leo. I don't --
I don't believe that. -Yeah.
You have to catch up to Jonah -- -Somebody has miscounted.
How many Jonah got?
-Jonah has 376, and you have 301.
-Just curse words or a specific curse word?
-No. Oh, that's interesting.
Because if it was THE curse word...
-Specific. -That one -- The one.
-The one. -You're the champ.
-Thank you. -Yeah, no problem.
-Thank you very much.
-Yeah, I wouldn't mess with that.
Come on. That list is ridiculous.
-Yeah. That's how I kicked off my Twitter account here.
-Yeah. Remember that? -Yes!
-We started -- You sent your first tweet --
-My first tweet came from here. -Yeah.
And do you remember what it was?
-"Can monkey fighters say 'fighter' on here?"
-Yeah, thank you. Thank you for editing yourself.
Thank you for editing yourself.
-"Can my friends say 'friend' on here?"
-Yeah, exactly. -Yeah, that.
-You did that here, but then --
Now I follow you on all the socials.
You're a great follow on Instagram, by the way.
I've been seeing a lot of your shirts.
-Ah.
-You have T-shirts that you wear.
Just let me show you, because it's super funny.
This is you.
This is you with your -- with Jules.
You're wearing a shirt with you as Jules
from "Pulp Fiction" right there.
-With a pin. With a pin of me as Jules.
-Wow.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-So, then, I like that.
But then here's your Nick Fury shirt.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-One of them. Yep, yep. -That's good.
-I got a gang of those. -Yeah, I like that one.
Then this one is -- this is your "Shaft" shirt.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
-You've got, like, kind of a meaner face.
-I sometimes try and match the faces on the shirts.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's, like, a meaner face.
-See what I can do, yeah.
-And then this is my favorite one.
This is you wearing you wearing the "Shaft" shirt.
Very meta. -Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And that's brilliant. That blew my mind.
-With my -- my eye depuffer for the morning.
-Is that -- -Yeah, that's what the --
Yeah, the little gold eye things in the morning.
You have to work for some glamour.
-Yeah, come on. To look this good?
Come on, bud. Yeah.
You know, you've been around for a while,
and there's a lot of kind of Internet rumors about you.
And I thought maybe we could squash
some of those rumors tonight if you don't mind, yeah.
Yeah, I'd like to maybe go through some myths
about you and you tell me if they're true or not true.
-I try not to read those. -All right, ready?
-Uh-huh, yeah. -Nothing's bad.
You once beat Tiger Woods in golf.
That can't be true. -Complete accident.
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-Well, the first time I ever played St Andrews,
they paired me with him
in what was the Dunhill Golf Tournament, and I was a 16.
So, they gave me my 16 shots, and I shot 78,
because he said, "Follow me."
And I stayed as close to him as I could and I shot 78.
-Wow!
-Which means I beat him by about 8 strokes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, come on. Not too shabby.
That's pretty cool. That's not that bad.
Uh...
Two, is it true that you own over 800 Kangol hats?
-My wife got rid of about 500 of them.
-Okay. So you're down to 300. -I'm down to 300.
-When did you start wearing those?
-Oh, geez, when I stole my first one
out of my grandfather's closet.
-Yeah. Exactly right. -Long, long time ago.
-Do you remember what color? Black?
-My grandfather's? -Yeah.
-No, it was like a --
It was a plaidy hat, you know? It's one of those patterns.
-Stylish, too, yeah. -Yeah.
-Number three, Samuel L. Jackson does not do
more than three takes of any scene in a movie.
Is that true?
-If I can help it. -Really?
-Well, I have to have a really good explanation
when you need more than three.
-Yeah, that's true. -Somebody's messing up.
Because it ain't me.
[ Laughter ]
It's like -- Is the focus puller --
"Is there anything I can do to make this better?
Can I help?" You know?
Or, "Do we need to hire somebody else?"
You know. -Yeah.
Did you ever have, like, a director that's going,
"Let's just do one for fun"?
-Yeah, I have them say that. -Yeah.
-And you don't do that? -No.
-No. I mean, because that's, like, crazy.
Because I don't get to go to the editing room.
And if they want to try something different,
that means they're going to look at that first,
because that's who they are.
And it's like -- I don't know. They don't get that option.
-I love you. That's just so good.
Oh, this one.
You had the "Star Wars" prop team
engrave your lightsaber with a special acronym.
Is that true?
-No, they did that because they loved me.
I didn't ask for it.
-They did that because they -- -When they gave it to me,
When the shoot was over, when they presented it to me,
it had "BMF" on the on/off button.
-Yeah, and what does "BMF" stand for?
-Bad, my friend.
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly right.
You're cool enough to actually take a photograph of this
so we can show it to everyone right here.
This is actually real.
I did not -- We've never seen this engravement.
Look right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about!
That's love for Samuel L. Jackson right there.
-Yes, it was. Yes, it was.
-Yeah, more with Samuel L. Jackson after the break.
We're gonna talk about his new Apple TV+ series.
Stick around.